en este vídeo vamos a explorar la
energía libre de jeeps y particularmente
su utilidad para determinar si una
reacción va a ser espontánea o no que es
muy útil en la química y en la biología
y fue definida por llosa ya willard
chips aquí tenemos la famosa fórmula que
nos va a ayudar a predecir la
espontaneidad de las reacciones y dice
que el cambio en la energía libre de
gips es igual al cambio en la en tal día
está h es entalpía puede ser vista como
el contenido de calor sobre todo porque
esta fórmula se aplica si estamos en
condiciones de presión y temperatura
constantes entonces el cambio en la
entropía - la temperatura multiplicada
por el cambio en la entropía la s es la
entropía
y parece que esta fórmula extraña es muy
difícil de entender pero veremos que en
realidad tiene mucho sentido intuitivo
gibbs llosa ya willard james definió
esto para saber cuántas en tal vía es
útil en la realización de trabajo cuánto
de ésta entalpía es libre para poder
hacer cosas útiles pero en este vídeo
vamos a enfocarnos en cómo podemos
utilizar el cambio en la energía libre
de gibbs para predecir si una reacción
va a ocurrir de forma espontánea y para
llegar directamente a saber esto vamos a
decir que si delta es menor que cero
nuestra reacción va a ser espontánea
va a hacer
es tan tan
va a suceder suponiendo que las
moléculas sean capaces de interactuar de
la forma correcta
va a ser espontánea ahora vamos a pensar
un poco acerca de por qué eso tiene
sentido si esta expresión es negativa
nuestra reacción va a ser espontánea
vamos a pensar en todos los diferentes
escenarios en este escenario si nuestro
cambio de entropía es menor que 0 y
nuestra entropía aumenta nuestra
entalpía disminuye esto significa que
vamos a liberar energía vamos a liberar
entalpía
liberar entalpía
terminó con menos en tal vía que con la
que empecé pero la entropía aumenta el
desorden aumenta el número de estados
que mi sistema puede asumir aumenta y
bueno esto tiene mucho sentido esto va a
suceder de manera espontánea
independientemente de la temperatura que
tengamos tengo estas dos moléculas están
a punto de chocar entre sí y cuando se
acercan una a la otra sus electrones
dicen espera aquí hay una mejor
configuración donde podemos entrar en un
estado de energía más bajo donde podemos
liberar energía y al hacerlo estos
diferentes componentes pueden separarse
y así tenemos más componentes ya que se
separaron y se liberó energía la
entropía aumenta y así esto tiene
sentido esto ocurre de manera natural
esto es espontáneo del traje es menor
que cero y voy a encerrar a las
reacciones espontáneas en color verde
ahora qué pasa con este escenario en
este escenario de la h es mayor que 0
por lo tanto la venta al día de esta
reacción tiene que aumentar y la
entropía va a disminuir puedes imaginar
que estas moléculas se acercan una a la
otra pero sus electrones dicen oye no no
para que podamos unirnos tendríamos que
llegar a un estado de energía más alto
vamos a necesitar energía y el desorden
va a disminuir esto no va a suceder y
así por supuesto esta es una combinación
y delta h es mayor que 0 y si éste es
menor que cero entonces todo este
término va a ser positivo y así delta g
va a ser mayor que 0 delta g va a ser
mayor que es 0
y espero que esto tenga sentido
intuitivo para ti esta reacción no va a
ser espontánea esta reacción no va a
suceder ahora aquí tenemos escenarios
donde delta h y delta s son iguales pero
lo que determina si estas reacciones son
espontáneas o no va a ser la temperatura
así que aquí si delta h es menor que
cero vamos a tener una liberación de
energía pero nuestra entropía disminuye
qué va a pasar aquí bueno si la
temperatura es baja estas moléculas o
estos átomos se van a acercar suavemente
uno al otro
y sus electrones van a poder interactuar
tal vez llegan a un estado de energía
más bajo y puedan liberar energía están
liberando energía y los electrones van a
hacer esto espontáneamente pero la
entropía va a bajar y esto puede suceder
espontáneamente porque la temperatura es
baja y algunos de ustedes podrían estar
diciendo espera que esto no va en contra
de la segunda ley de la termodinámica
y hay que recordar que la entropía si
solo estás pensando en esta parte del
sistema
entonces si va en contra de la segunda
ley de la termodinámica pero se está
liberando calor y el calor va a añadir
entropía al resto del sistema y la
segunda ley de la termodinámica sostiene
que la entropía del universo va a
aumentar debido a este calor liberado
pero si sólo nos fijamos en los
constituyentes la entropía disminuye por
lo tanto esto va a ser espontáneo
también y si regresamos a la fórmula si
esto es negativo y esto es negativo esto
va a ser un término positivo pero si t
es lo suficientemente baja este término
no va a tener importancia
la temperatura es un factor importante
para la entropía así que si te es
pequeña la entropía no va a tener
importancia
entonces la entalpía domina la ecuación
por lo tanto en esta situación la
temperatura es lo suficientemente baja
para hacer que delta g
a negativo y esto va a ser espontáneo
aquí tenemos el mismo escenario pero
tenemos una temperatura alta tenemos las
mismas dos moléculas digamos que estas
son las moléculas esta es esta morada de
aquí tenemos las mismas dos moléculas
aquí que podrían liberar energía pero
aquí el cambio en la antártida es
negativo pero están moviéndose tan
rápido que sus electrones no van a tener
la oportunidad de interactuar de la
forma correcta para que la reacción
ocurra esta es una situación en la que
la reacción no será espontánea porque
solo van a pasarse de largo no van a
tener la oportunidad de interactuar
correctamente y así si la temperatura es
alta si t es alta
este término va a ser muy importante y
el hecho de que la entropía es negativa
va a ser que este término sea positivo y
esto va a ser más positivo de lo que
esto va a ser negativo por lo tanto esta
es una situación en la que nuestro delta
g es mayor que 0
así que esta reacción es no espontánea
y todo lo que estoy haciendo es solo
para que entiendas por qué esta fórmula
para la energía libre de gates tiene
sentido y recuerda esto es cierto a
presión constante y a temperatura
constante y esas son suposiciones
razonables si estamos utilizando un tubo
de ensayo o si estamos hablando de una
gran cantidad de sistemas biológicos
ahora vamos a ver este caso
aquí nuestro cambio en la entropía es
positivo y nuestra entropía aumentaría
si éstas reaccionan pero nuestra
temperatura es baja si estas moléculas
reaccionan tal vez se separarían y
harían algo como esto pero éstas no van
a hacer eso porque cuando estas
moléculas chocan entre sí podrían decir
todos nuestros electrones tienen unas
agradables configuraciones estables no
veo ninguna razón para reaccionar a
pesar de que si lo hiciéramos ganaríamos
un aumento en la entropía no hay razón
para reaccionar y si nos fijamos en
estas variables si ese es positivo y si
este es positivo si la temperatura es
baja este término no va a ser capaz de
vencer a este otro por lo que el delta g
es mayor que cero
no espontánea si vemos el mismo
escenario y decidimos subir la
temperatura aumentar la energía cinética
promedio estas moléculas van a ser
capaces de chocar entre sí y a pesar de
que los electrones van a requerir algo
de energía para formar estos enlaces
esto puede suceder porque tenemos todo
este desorden que está siendo creado
tenemos más estados y es menos probable
ir en el otro sentido porque bueno
cuáles son las probabilidades de que
estas moléculas simplemente se reúnan en
la configuración exacta para volver a
tener este número menor de moléculas y
si nos fijamos en estas variables
incluso si delta h es mayor que 0
incluso si esto es positivo si delta s
es mayor que 0 y t es alta este término
se va a convertir especialmente con el
signo negativo aquí este término va a
vencer al cambio en la entropía y hacer
que toda la expresión sea
así que aquí delta que va a ser menor
que 0 y esta reacción va a ser
espontánea espero que esto te ayude a
entender la fórmula de energía libre de
jeeps y tienes que recordar que sólo
funciona si la presión y la temperatura
son constantes pero es útil para pensar
acerca de si una reacción es espontánea
y conforme veamos sistemas biológicos o
químicos verás el del traje de las
reacciones y podrás decir oh es un
mensaje negativo esa va a ser una
reacción espontánea o el mensaje es
igual a cero esto va a ser un equilibrio
o podrías decir esto es un delta hé
positivo
esta reacción va a ser no espontánea